it has been such a special week here in
cleveland
the way they're finishing and going into
the playoffs it's been a wild
ride for the tribe and it's not over yet
because these next two games
could determine where they end up
playing on tuesday
brian hayes six-game hitting streak and
329
batting average in his 23rd major league
game there's the 2-2 pitch
and a ball slammed out to right and a
base hit for hayes it's into the corner
he's around first heading into second
and key brian hayes with a one-out
double
colin morani's the dh tonight
that was hard hit up the middle a base
hit and right away the pirates will take
a one-nothing lead
the double for hayes the single for
moran that's his 20th rbi
joe musgrove joe owen five got to get
him a win here tonight
here's the 2-2 and his swing but
it hit him strike three and he runs down
to first base but
he's gonna have to run back to third
base well look how
far this ball it hit him in the thigh
how could that be
[Applause]
that is how is that possible uh you know
a great hitter
like lenore that that is uh something
else
two balls and two strikes the center of
the pitch a swing in the fly ball hit
deep to right
carrying well naquin back and it's gone
over the wall a home run
the opposite way for jose osuna
home run number three and the pirates
are up two to nothing
a home run for osuna his third
and it's two nothing pace with a
seven-game hitting streak now after that
first inning double and he slams one out
to
right center and the shields can't get
it it's past him and it's gonna trickle
to the wall
hayes around first heading into second
hayes has his second double and as many
at bats tonight
as hayes is the third with one away for
josh bell
hits this pass first into right three
nothing
sharply hit by josh bell to bring home
hayes
the pirates have scored a run in each of
the first three innings
here's brian reynolds swung on hammer to
deep left center field this is
all kinds of trouble gone an opposite
field two run the home run to left
center by brian
reynolds and it's the worst dotting of
the year for aaron sivali
it's a five-nothing pirate lead here in
the third inning
pirates are up five nothing in the
fourth helen moran
singled in the first run in the first
grounded out in the third
launches this ball to deep right field
and clear the
deck cannonball coming it's
colin moran don't you know he hit all
the way to
county cork with number ten three-run
blast for
colin moran and the route is on for the
pirates now
as pittsburgh has taken an eight-nothing
lead over the try
pirates leading eight to nothing in
cleveland bottom of the order against
joe musgrove 3-2 pitch swinging a foul
tip struck him out on an
outside curveball out of the zone
asking if he offered and he did it's a
strikeout
muskrat with seven strikeouts tonight oh
big joe's going to go back
out for the seventh he's not going to
get the pitch for a while so
why not got him on the breaking ball the
musgrove curveball that's number nine
and he has set down
12 straight looks like a whistleblower
look at this thing just disappear
and it's one and two we're in the
seventh pirates are up
eight to nothing in the pitch swung on
and missed struck him out
for musgrove 10 strikeouts tonight
over seven scoreless innings brian hayes
leading off here
in the top of the ninth looking for his
fifth hit
two other rookie third baseman in
pirates history
since 1901 i've had five hits in the
game
he's reached base safely in six straight
plate appearances
drive to right center field he's done it
he's
five for five key brian hayes
five for five it's his third double
and he joins wayneer and brubaker and
he's hitting it like a man
that's what i like about that he's
hitting it like a man he's driving the
ball
no little bloopers or infield hits
he just makes it look easy i tell you
that is just
smooth swinging two on with two out
oscar mercado's first at bat
and this should do it reynolds
will squeeze it and will raise the jolly
roger in a big way
in cleveland ohio
joe musgrove goes seven shutout innings
and key brian hayes
sparks this offense going five for five
becomes the
third rookie third baseman
in modern pirates history to collect
five hits in a game
what